ANGELA CREAGER: When both
ordinary people and scholars
have thought about the legacy
of the Manhattan Project,
we thought about the way in
which physics and engineering
were put to military use.
We thought about a destructive
legacy, the arms race, the Cold
War.
Part of what I discovered
was that atomic energy
had just as much of a legacy
in some of the fields that we
think of as peaceable as
it did in military uses.
And specifically here, a lot of
the advances in postwar biology
and medicine that have been
really taken for granted
owe a lot to the
materials and the policies
that were part of
the Cold War US.
When the Manhattan
Project resulted
in the invention of
nuclear reactors,
many scientists working
for the Manhattan Project
understood that this would be
a tremendous source, especially
for the production of
radioactive isotopes.
NARRATOR: What
are radioisotopes?
They are merely unstable
forms of elements giving off
unseen particles, or
rays, from the nuclei
during the process of
changing to stable form.
ANGELA CREAGER:
Initially, the hope
was that radioisotopes could
be used to cure cancer.
So there was a great
hope that perhaps cancer
could be treated by finding
a magic bullet for every kind
of cancer, a different
kind of radioisotope that
might localize to
a tissue and kill
a tumor from within the body.
And there are some cancers that
are susceptible to radioisotope
treatment, although, in the
end, it was more a replacement
for radium as an
external radiation
source than a completely
revolutionary, new kind
of treatment.
So those uses were
already known.
In addition, the discovery
of stable isotopes
had already led to trace
reuses of isotopes.
Trace reuses are
when you replace
one atom of a compound with a
particular radiolabeled atom
so that you can
follow that label
through the ordinary chemical
or biological processes
that that compound goes through.
And so radiotracing
was very widely
applicable to
study biochemistry,
physiology, endocrinology,
eventually ecology.
Basically anything where a
chemical compound is in motion,
radiotracing is a way to
look at change over time
and look at chemical
transformations.
There was still this great
hope that radioisotopes
were going to do great
things for humankind.
There was a story about
the medical dividends
of atomic energy that features
a very striking color image.
It shows a man,
who's in his pajamas,
having stood up from
a wheelchair, who
is encircled in this
halo of a mushroom cloud.
And the suggestion
is that he has
been healed of whatever ailment
had him in that wheelchair
by the power of the atom.
I think it captures better
than any other single image
the hopeful side.
Certainly people understood
that at high levels
radiation was very dangerous.
But it was over the course
of the 1950s and 1960s
that the hazards of
low-level radiation
came into clearer view.
And that complicated
the hope that radiation
and radioisotopes could be
beneficial for civilians,
because certainly
their use would expose
some people to low
levels of radioactivity.
So then it became
more of a calculation
of when the risk
was worth taking.
And in most cases
today, people feel
like low-level risks associated
with dental X-rays or tests
in hospitals are worth it to
get the benefits of radiation
and radioisotopes.
But people are more leery
about the risks of radiation
from nuclear power
and other kinds
of environmental contamination.